excuse me that's enough
when you report fake news which cnn does
a lot
you are the enemy of the people cnn
should be ashamed of itself
having you working for them
it's like in a state of shock i'm not
thinking about that that's okay i know
you're not thinking you never do
i'm sorry what a stupid question that is
what a stupid question
but i watch you a lot you ask a lot of
stupid questions
i want to have that fight with you hey
all right should we have another fight
with you
it's okay in the meantime i'm president
and you're not
good i don't know do i seem rattled
[Music]
subject for today
um there you go it's a very nice gift
that was a step where i had a little bit
more distance between that's sort of
like taking like oh
home range right keeping it at the jab
with my tongue it's just a little bit
longer
you think a little further it's
whoa oh okay okay
the science i can do it all day that's
like a liberal by the way i want to ask
people do you know
uh what is the inspiration for that
intro for good morning mug club
french canadians you will probably know
uh wasn't a very good show
nor a very good intro um but today's
going to be a good
one fantastic totally different than
that donald j
trump the president has been nominated
for the nobel peace prize
oh man we're going to be talking about
that my half asian lawyer is back in uh
half asian bill richmond how are you sir
wonderful very nice he makes uh he makes
better use of that chair than gerald b
how are you geraldine i am doing well
bring back gerald b well
no he used to hate him well you put him
you put him against bill and it's uh
it's a toss-up most of the time really i
love you gerald i don't agree
quarterback garrett is here we're gonna
be talking about a whole lot we're going
to be talking about the nobel peace
prize we're going to be talking about
daniel prude and why that police
interaction was uh
almost exemplary um
don't blame the police blame the fouchy
hood oh uh and we'll also be talking
about uh joe biden and his recent
history lessons at the town hall
he drank a bucket of salt water
every time never do that before you go
the guy is just so
wrong remember when everyone thought
that daniel quayle
put his foot in his mouth yeah one
thought dan quail potato was it
misspelled potato was that what it was
he added an e to potato
there's no e potato e i don't know what
he did he misspelled it
you have joe biden who gets it wrong as
to who invented the light bulb
i thought that was settled science
people think that's a joke we're going
to get to that story
he actually it's not a joke we're
excited
that somebody invented a light bulb who
was not thomas edison who
unless you think it's a it's it's a bait
and switch thomas i just said invented
the light
oh yeah it's one of those things we were
like maybe the answer's so obvious it's
not what i think it's exactly what you
think no yeah
there's no reveal i mean it's one of
those questions where you just you
you assume you got to just be in the
wrong because it's such an obviously
wrong answer right
you're like oh i mean like you know
there's no brontosaurus anymore okay
get it right nope he's just wrong would
you think that 400 horsepower
is more powerful which most people think
or less powerful than 300 horsepower and
because you say which is what most
people think people go
oh i'm most people i must be wrong no
it's exactly what you think 400
horsepower is more than 300
questions really quickly let's go to the
cnn uh where they're saying that the
white house
wants to know the winner on election
night oh my gosh what a freaking
nightmare
yeah well yeah we have a whole segment
on this that the democrats do
we're going to do it tomorrow because we
wanted to talk about the nobel peace
prize but the democrats do want to steal
this election they already have plans
for civil unrest i mean
more civil unrest yeah if donald trump
wins
or if donald trump it doesn't matter
there's going to be more civil unrest
but
this is what's crazy to me this idea
that donald trump wants to erode trust
in american institutions by
by using the same method for the
election as we've used
always forever every every time
that conservative approach is baloney
he's stuck in the past stephen
it takes two weeks now old stuff this is
a man who wants to erode the tradition
of christmas how so we put a christmas
tree up
you know who will really change
celebrating the birth of our savior
jesus christ
we wanted to do a pagan altar exactly
that's what we want the pagan altar
yeah i mean you know what i do but i
really you know what i really do have to
give it to the democrats because if
you're if you're complaining about your
old white guy president
sticking with these old tired methods of
voting you know the best thing to do is
to
oh wait another one
my question to you is do you think that
president trump deserves a nobel peace
prize i'll be honest
i don't really know that i do but i
don't know that anybody really deserves
one it's a [ __ ] prize and certainly
barack obama didn't deserve one for
doing nothing
so literally but first this is a clip
that was playing it was making the
rounds yesterday i just had to address
it because there seems to be a lot of
race-baiting coming from the dnc
i see yeah you would think right when i
say there seems to be a lot lately
that would make one that would give one
pause like wait a second i thought they
always were but i shouldn't speak
because
it must be so obvious i don't know it's
exactly what you think they've been
consistently race-baiting and this is
just bringing it to a crescendo
between uh professional uh bodybuilding
correspondent chris cuomo
and uh john uh face lemon let's watch
if you talk to women honestly they will
tell you if you're a man
and you haven't you haven't taken
advantage of
the privilege or the advantages you have
in this society
then maybe you're doing it wrong if you
speak to some people of color they will
tell you the same thing if you're a
white person
and you have not taken advantage of
being able to always get loans always
get an education
always vote always have every priority
even if you're
poor always if you haven't been able to
take advantage of that
then maybe you're doing it wrong but you
should not be blaming the people who
don't have agency in society
along with you i'm watching a gay black
rapidly aging host in prime time with a
slot that he doesn't deserve
largely exclusively because he's gay and
black
alongside always in a split screen with
a man who has a prime time slot
solely because of his brother he's the
lesser he's the entourage dylan
of cuomo if you're not taking advantage
you're doing it wrong
well hold on a second white people can
always
get a loan even if they're even if
they're poor what if your credit is shot
what do you really think that if you
apply for a loan on
and now you can do these things online
you can go when i go into the bank by
the way i go into the
i don't understand what they're doing it
doesn't matter how much money i have
with the bank
i go and i say hey but i have all this
money in these accounts with you and
could i get an extension in the line of
credit just for and they go no
i said what do you mean like it doesn't
matter how much money it doesn't matter
what relationship we have
i'm going to punch it into the system i
go do you mean you're going to bank of
america dot com because i too
can go to bank of america and request a
credit limit and then it will say
see me me and now i'm seeing you and
you're not doing anything do you really
think that if you're a black person and
you're applying online or you're going
and you have a credit score of what's
like 7
40 ah you would have been approved but
oh melanin it doesn't happen
no this has to be a segment on the
stupid things that people say that are
untrue right that's what he's got to be
saying to us like hey there's these
morons out there that say this
and here's what they say but no this is
don lemon saying that this is gospel
you know what he's referring back to
redlining which was like in the sixties
yeah well i'm bad at math building check
out what he's referring to 60 years
referring to he just listed a whole
bunch of things i know he listed those
things that's the last time that there
was a concerted effort you know what
happened when they had the financial
crisis
and meltdown they said that banks were
actually lending too much to black
people who couldn't afford it
yes now we've gone full circle and
saying they're not lending to them at
all at all
that's never happened but they are
giving loans to every white person yes
yeah haven't you guys seen the white
bank predatory lending
you ever hear that it's like what is
print let's break that down for a second
what is predatory lending it's where
these people who lend money uh-huh they
usually lend money
to get it paid back with interest so
that's how they make money
yes so they make money by giving loans
out that are paid back
with interest right but then they find
people who they know can never pay it
back and they give them the money
well then how do they make money
oh because these are guaranteed by the
government the government forced them to
the government pressured them saying you
are going to lend to people who have no
business paying it back you're going to
give them homes right now you can look
at
uh dodd-frank fannie mae freddie mac
this is what happened with predatory
lending and then they started packaging
them up and you can watch the big short
i get it i like steve carell too
but the point that they don't tell you
they businesses if there's no
incentive to make a profit if your
business is lending money so that
someone pays it back
and then some and they can't pay it back
it doesn't make any business sense
outside of the fact that we had people
in the federal government who decided to
be
social justice warriors in chief who
made sure that banks were lending
to people who couldn't pay it back this
predatory lending it's the stupidest
thing anyone
who lets the words predatory lending
leave their lips
deserves to be roasted with their own
christmas turkey with a steak of holly
driven through their hearts
this side and it's so divisive think
about this there's some white kid out
there right now
by the way could be an african-american
it could be a little elon musk
a little charlize the run little aeon
flux for all you know
who's out there who's being raised in
the hills of west virginia in the back
of an
airstream probably not an airship
because there's a more expensive design
or whatever the generic
version is not all aluminum you know
it's like kind of whatever it is steel
panel
is it aluminum it's cheap i don't know i
don't know your streams are expensive i
blame steve jobs
[Laughter]
it's nice design that's the word now oh
design oh thank you
there's some kid out there watching this
right now and he's seeing some black kid
in a prep school who has
all of his opportunities served two on a
plate and of course there are examples
of white people have that but there are
white people right now who are living in
poverty who don't have a father
maybe they're a crack baby they don't
have a leg up in life and they're
hearing don
lemon sit there chastise them for not
taking advantage of the system well how
is it
how is a young poor white person with no
credit gonna take advantage of the
system there's no affirmative action
well there's no hiring quota there's no
advantage to
being he's not a woman he's not a
minority of any kind
and because of people like you you
racist prick everyone assumes that he's
had everything spoon fed to him
when in fact it's just the opposite
there are no systemic
advantages afforded to people as far as
far as the result of government policy
of
young white underprivileged poor
white men none that cannot be said about
any other group
women minorities minorities who are poor
minority women
z's where your guess is as good as mine
and the coroner goes i don't know what
to do with this [ __ ]
the point is young white poor men
really have a raw deal and it's even
more raw because of people like you who
look at them as though they're the
rockefellers right and they're supposed
to be taking advantage of the system i
grew up in that system i was
relatively middle low class my parents
didn't graduate high school my dad got a
job you didn't have a tooth
i know i had to get it put back in moved
13 times before i graduated high school
because of course we could get a loan we
just didn't want to yeah i mean it was
too much work to go down to the bank and
be like
remember can i get the white money for
the house oh
okay we just didn't do that yeah 13
times before i graduated from high
school
yeah i was white it's tough because then
you have to call to have your white
privilege card replaced and then there's
a process and a new security a little
strip on the back
auto filled in all my apple accounts and
now i got a new auto fill my white
privilege i can't do it no
you know what they do now when you try
to go get your white privilege card they
just take the crest white strips you
know
teeth whitening games they just hold it
up to you and you're like oh you're a
three all right here you go here's the
what do you
know you're yellow no i know i'm a seven
on the scale
oh yeah that's true where's the color
until you're useful for that
think about think about how patronizing
it has to be to hear
a rich black man on tv with his
rich white buddy look down on you and go
if you're a poor white person
you have every advantage in the world
you can get any loan
every democratic voter every hipster on
the street who can't get a loan because
they're
on their seventh phd whatever it may be
it doesn't matter whether you're
republican or democrat or libertarian or
whatever it may be
if you are poor and your skin isn't dark
or non-white they're saying that you
have every advantage in the world if you
don't believe that
you need to look somewhere else yeah
well don lemon's actually right
there are people out there that believe
that and the only reason they do is
because they've listened to people like
don lemon for too long
speaking of uh loudmouth minorities
right now on cnn fauci stresses
importance of minority participation in
vaccine trials
we're politicizing vaccine trials i mean
i would assume that it needs the proper
amount of minority representation as you
would deal with the population in other
words i don't want someone who has some
sort of a genetic
phenotype or something that's going to
react poorly but what do we need do you
see this with the oscars diversity
they're going to have diversity
representation nominated for the oscars
so great great great all those in five
years from now the nominations are going
to be nothing but tyler medea's number
four and offenses too and right now with
with
vaccine trials how are they by the way
how are they going to approach somebody
how is that not a violation of
non-discrimination practices
uh okay and uh are you black how do you
feel about needles
we need more black lab rats is that what
she is telling us
lab rats black vaccines matter stephen
we need more black lab rats because
we're not going to test this on
animals we need more minority
participation this this doctor
foundation
all the time the racism it is unreal to
me by the way please do we're going to
be talking about the nobel peace prize
here in a little bit um
do join up mug club lottery with
credit.com mug club that's the only
thing that allows us to continue doing
these
programs and you get all kinds of
exclusive content there like another 45
minutes every day
extended interviews um and of course
we're available in apple podcasts
and the spotify and android and all that
stuff google play um it's not something
that's
spotify like uh joe rogan here but no
all right donald trump everywhere was
just
nominated for the nobel peace prize you
can't find this it's the number one
trend
you can't find them talking about it
anywhere uh in media we had to go to the
jerusalem post
oh wow that's uh that's foreign that's
not in the united states
is it i'm not entirely sure it could be
owned by an american company that's a
lot of these companies
that's true that's true i really like
this so the guy from norway who
nominated him
he was quoted as saying as reported by
fox news
i'm not a big trump supporter the
committee should look at the facts and
judge him on the facts
not on the way he behaves sometimes the
people who've received the peace prize
in recent years
have done much less than donald trump
for example barack obama did nothing
by the way the norwegian guy the reason
you would find jerusalem post is because
of the
the deal with israel and the uae kind of
nerdy but listen i'm sure you realize
not good bad fellows and that's likely
to change the uae may turn around
i'm always confused about this because
uae declared care a terrorist
organization i thought oh maybe they
were coming around but it turns out it's
just because of some kind of a
weird sort of incestuous rivalry with
qatar
ah it's like the bloods being anti-crip
yes yeah exactly they're still throwing
women in the back of a truck
if they happen to work before a man into
a revolving door so
they haven't necessarily reached the
zenith of progress yet
that was the worst argument you know
this that i got into with my wife early
on oh yeah she was supposed to go to
dubai
this is a true story sorry sweetheart
she was supposed to go to dubai and
it was the first time i was a husband i
said no no no i said no she's like what
can we talk about no
no we're not going to talk about it and
then i got my parents and i said listen
she doesn't understand the security
measures that need to be taken you know
being married to me this was kind of a
blast of cold water
and then she was pushing and then i
became pediatric i said you know what by
the way
no europe either no more europe is off
the table
get it out no oh nice well the entire
country of pakistan wanted to kill you
so i mean of course
could be it is true in dubai so yeah you
know i'm sure that's not the only
country do they expire or do they just
continue in perpetuity
i don't know the rules with the new
ayatollahs and the fat ones i mean
they're still in the parking lot waiting
yeah oh okay well that's yeah i wave at
him i'm like hey guys
there could be another ayatollah who's a
louder with crowder fan but i wouldn't
hold my price
you know what i was really hoping is
that this would resurrect your obama got
a peace prize rap video
yeah i was hoping that that should come
out of the archives
so barack obama got it surprised by the
way uh
very shortly into his presidency this
was like about three or four months if
i'm not mistaken
and a part of me feels as though i i
mean barack obama maybe even didn't want
it i want to believe that right so maybe
he's not that self-obsessed narcissist
that we believe all politicians to be
like he woke up and they probably said
hey hey listen hey uh hey barack
you're going to get the peace prizes and
you're [ __ ] me did you hear about
the drums yeah
you know in public he actually was like
i don't deserve this right
the people other people have really done
something and i've done nothing every
universally people were like yep he's
only been here 200 days like
what's going on well he was given uh the
peace prize for
capturing the world's attention and
given its people hope for a better
future
so i don't know if they can rescind it
after eight years and they see the
economy oh it didn't work out
yeah just like like uh like the grinch
with the candy canes pulling out while
the kids are sleeping
that's what they should do with barack
obama's prize exactly and by the way
peace is in the name this is i don't
this is one of the things that i will
tell you okay
i don't know what it really is all right
i don't really know what the nobel peace
prize is because barack obama
longest war time in modern american
history for presidents
they were bashing donald trump for being
ant military the other day i don't think
he's anti-military i do think he's
anti-war he's probably the most anti-war
president that i can think of in recent
memory
um well one of the one of the statistics
was that he is the first president who
has not
started in an international armed
conflict in 39 years
wow and the last president who went that
long won the nobel peace prize
jimmy carter right well very nice nice
good for him well he goes for him first
freaking few months okay so that stat
doesn't matter jerk jimmy carter got in
the first few months no
obama he was talking about jimmy carter
are you drunk he said both he was
talking about obama and comparing
the carter and i was giving him a heart
saying that jimmy carter was the only
one who didn't start an international
conflict now the difference
that's right with donald trump jimmy
carter was a [ __ ]
well he knew he didn't ring a hammer but
that was about it yeah knew
he loved his peanuts and his sweaters
nice um but
it doesn't mean anything to me because
nobel peace prize peace is in the name
yeah
94 is given to yasser arafat now for
people going wait wait a second
that name rings a bell uh it should be
ding ding ringing the terrorist bell oh
he was a terrorist he was the founder of
the palestinian liberations
liberation organization he was the one
who invented
hijacking that was his signature that's
all they do if he applies for a loan
which is guaranteed to him because he's
not black according to don lemon
they just look at his hijacking he's the
thomas edison
hijacker they don't compare signatures
they go how many people
assumed room temperature on his last
commercial flight
ah it's yes or arafat let's give him a
peace prize they gave it to yasser
arafat they gave it to
al gore for drawing attention to climate
change they said to this
he they're giving it to him al gore was
in 2007 the quote was from nobel prize
to disseminate greater knowledge about
man-made climate change and to lay the
foundations for measures that are needed
to counteract such change
uh by the way british high court ruled
that uh his uh film contained nine
significant errors that had to be
corrected
just because they're concerned about the
bull crap being taught to children
they have higher standards than whatever
it is for the nobel peace prize we can
all act here like we know
no none of us really know exactly what
gets you on the new york times
bestseller list i'm just sort of pulling
back the curtain here so you know we can
talk about this as though we know
i don't know and i don't really give it
much stock when it's terrorist
jimmy carter barack obama after three
months
al gort they all got peace prizes not to
mention this one which i love
in 2012 it was given to the european
union no specific individual
just the general precept of the european
union
brexit folks this is like they're all
sitting around and they're like
yeah uh man what do i have something to
do in like 10 minutes
oh oh crap look at the testing we're
gonna give it
they looked around and said well we've
been doing a pretty good job and we need
a little bit more right now look at us
how about we recognize us who do you
notify with the eu
too like i don't know i'm late i'm late
uh he's eating like a payday
eu who me yeah you
look if if obama had done what trump has
done with this peace deal with
israel and the uae he would have gotten
a second peace prize
this would be plastered all over the
media right this is a huge deal that
history books later on will look back
and go
yeah that's kind of a big deal you know
that trump has done this and you're
seeing
almost no coverage of it at all and by
the way i think this is a great contrast
to the fact that someone can be a
bombastic prick which donald trump is
let's be honest agreed but he's our
bombastic sometimes
uh and get things done and avoid armed
conflict and actually broker peace deals
and then someone can be a you know
like msnbc uh lean forward bend over
barack obama go out there and act like
he wants to be peaceful everyone just
takes advantage of him yeah he doesn't
have the option because no one really
believes that he's gonna do anything
well and that's kind of like
the democrats didn't like reagan because
he was standing up to the soviet union
he was pushing too hard leading us into
war he was definitely one of these war
hawks right and then all of a sudden
it's like oh
they only respected power it turned out
a single person found a more peaceful
life due to that wall being torn down
true it's remarkable people who want
peace but they do so at the expense of
millions of other people not being able
to live peacefully
that's why i wouldn't fault donald trump
if there's a war if there's a 911 that
happens under his watch
obviously something needs to be done
about it but he is a man who has been
known he's spoken out against the iraq
war
he has a more consistent record of being
anti-war before he was bro
and listen we're lucky in this sense
that with with barack obama we didn't
know
we don't even know how he got an
occidental okay i assume he probably
went ah
ah ah you need to meet a quota ah listen
get on in here barack that name's gonna
look
good when we send this for a federal
grant donald trump
we know everything that he believed
before he was president because he was a
reality tv host and he can never shut up
barack obama we know nothing we know
nothing about where he was
raised he mostly voted president as a
junior senator effectively a state
senator
this was a guy we don't have his college
records we don't know how he got into
these colleges all we know that was
according to him he was doing cocaine
with bill ayers a convicted domestic
terrorist
and with donald trump you go what did he
think about war 12 years ago
oh let me look through this esquire
interview where he talks about how he
doesn't like
shaking hands with people who are poor
and then he says i don't like wood
it's for [ __ ] that's what he thought
eight years ago
there's no guesswork he's an open book
and he's trying not to draw red lines
and then walk away from them either he
draws a red line
and then he executes on it he's like oh
okay you guys gonna do this fine this is
what i said i was gonna do
here we go i did it for crying out loud
he gets mad and calls a reporter
semi-retarded what do you think's gonna
happen when he counts to three
with with syria now now
syria pretty quiet the iranian
revolutionary guard leader he found out
uh
exactly he found out what you guys want
to screw around and shoot down drones
and try to mess with our ships and stuff
no okay yeah okay we got you covered you
know you know what what we haven't yet
seen is that like miracle on 34th street
you know where all the letters come in
and they're like damn you trump i can't
believe you killed that terrorist
all i want for christmas is another
terrorist please
no that's not happening when you look at
the history of what's happening in the
middle east considering what's been done
for for a man who's been labeled the
most divisive
racist anti-foreign xenophobic
president and yet this is what he's
brokering oh yeah
i mean it breaks the narrative yeah and
every single person on the left has
every every opportunity they've taken
like this is going to start world war
three this is going to push iran to the
brink right now there's
there's just no need for this what
happened did anybody see world war three
did it happen i want to push her into
the brink i want him hanging by a very
thin thread and i will
dig it if i see that i want to see i
want to see iran
just barely hanging on so donald trump
can go eventually
and they blow off and then they're just
like a trash bag blowing in the wind
like an art house film
when kevin spacey shows up doing the
neighbor
hey you wanna let let's think about
let's think about this what let what was
one of the precipitating factors that
moved into world war ii
evaporation condensation precipitation
rain come again another day go ahead all
of those
waters but neville chamberlain cow
towing to nazi germany
and what does it sound like when you're
being told you know no
man you know what iran we should just
let them do their thing like
why can't they have nukes can they just
have terrorists
yeah it's fine yeah yeah yeah you know
what it's fine georgia they just want to
they just want to get near the
mediterranean
like just let them do their thing yeah
exactly understand it's a it's a
temperate climate they need some olive
trees
but it's this kind of refusing to draw a
line like you were saying gerald that
really just creates the problems where
you know on the left they're just saying
yeah you know it's fine like it doesn't
matter if we define a man or a woman
doesn't matter if we define marriage
doesn't matter if we define what
countries are it doesn't matter what
borders are
just tear it all down it's totally fine
except when you go okay great well
they're all going to move to california
well
no i think you should take your fair
share of the immigrants right right
no it's a good point i don't even think
you just realized you laid out the case
the left
refuses to uh allow definitions to exist
of things that are real for example
male and female for example national
borders these are things that can
actually be quantified they're not just
some unknown variable but for some
reason they always seek to
identify things like hate speech which
are non-existent
they are the the enemy of the modern
progressive left
is reality they will tell you that you
are anti-science when you go on a second
are male and female a thing no all right
um hold on a second are national borders
a thing
i don't think they should be all right
tell me about hate speech well really
it's if it makes somebody feel bad or
and that's something else that i want to
touch on people are getting mad right
now they use this example with donald
trump wanting that uh
wasn't even that griffin at fox news
being fired i think she is she the
silver-haired
sort of lesbian looking uh reporter who
had that she looks like sharon stone now
not sharon stone with a
legs crosstalk oh yeah not fetching
sharon stone but sharon stone where you
go
today's sharon's done he wanted her
fired and i saw people on cnn and people
in the online lecture
saying uh oh this is the president who
supports cancer culture more than anyone
hold on a second hold on a second
this is something that's really silly
but people do it a lot for example a
conservative says
hey you know what i really disagree with
the fact that bernie sanders thinks a 90
tax rate is okay are you triggered no no
no trigger
means you find something offensive that
wasn't intended to be offensive and
you're trying to recreate
rules for societal interactions okay
cancel culture is where you try to
cancel somebody
for saying something that isn't
inherently offensive but you don't like
it
it's not the same as saying hey that
person lied and they should be held
accountable for their
lie this is a remarkable to me the left
always tries to hijack it but again
because they don't have definitions of
what actually exists they go oh i know
yeah triggered is the same thing for
example if this person says they're
triggered because you use masculine
pronouns despite the fact that you could
literally see his dick at the folsom
street fair
it's the same thing if i say you're
triggered because uh i said that donald
trump is uh convicted rapist no no i'm
not triggered i'm just correcting you
he's not a convicted rapist trigger
trigger trigger
i want to hit you hard exactly hey don't
don't forget one of the biggest lines
that's just being blurred we talked
about this last week
yeah man child oh that's right
the age that relates to what is
pedophilia and the story we talked about
last week and
and how a a government elected official
in california is trying to just go
yeah the line no big deal give or take a
few cubes uh
let's go to repulsive it is repulsive it
is
that's the state of chaos that's the
state it's the law
and but this is where i get upset
sometimes i hate this but i'm just kind
of getting on my my soapbox with
christian conservatives we're like why
are you talking about the fact that
people aren't
engaging in anal sex with minors because
it's legal
yeah it's the law in california you
can't this is the problem too that
people enjoy a luxury sometimes people
talk about
this sort of divided america what i do
see happening more
is this grand stating and i see people
and i have family and friends and
relatives who are christians and what
happens they live two separate lives
they go to the church and they held up
their hand and praise and worship and
then they separate that from their life
at work where they keep their opinion to
themselves for fear of losing their job
we don't have that luxury so we have to
address what's actually going on in
person
just like people on the left that's what
they do they have their life that they
live in their echo chamber
and then they get around and all of a
sudden they take off their antifa garb
and they don't really sucker punch
somebody in the office because they have
to work in a cubicle next to him for the
rest of the day
our life we have to discuss what is
going on and we are in a country
where we have a state where someone
can have sex with a 14 year old even if
they're 24
and it won't go on any record that's the
reality
yeah we're going to address it and make
some pee-pee jokes so
let's move on everyone is a little
uncomfortable
it's time to go it's time for a history
lesson but first let's start with
this week in joe biden wait if you have
a problem figuring out whether you're
for me or trump then you ain't black
they would say that you want to uh
defund the police and
it seems to be uh trying to frighten
some folks uh can you can you set the
record straight on that
the only person calling to defund the
police is
is donald trump wait if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or trump then you ain't black
oh well yeah all right by the way don't
you love how they moved from when they
were first saying don't wear masks
they're like wash your hands don't touch
your face
no one's talking about not touching your
face anymore because it's impossible to
wear a mask
joe biden just violated the first rule
of mask fight club
you're not supposed to touch the map no
by the way why does he have to wear a
mask when he's like eight feet away from
reporters like i i it's the virtue
it's politically pleasing just take it
off and talk into the microphone sir
someone just dress him up like a geisha
and send him to an opium den he won't
know where he is he'll live out the
remaining days
happily
should we raise a fund for that let's do
it
raise the fund for joe biden's last days
in an opium debt
you know who's the first one
contributing kamala
she's like after the election i was
promised five days in
five days in january i just wanted to
include that because i thought that was
pretty funny that's one of those i don't
even know if we address the only person
who wants to defund the police is
donald trump okay listen
fast forward that clip just extend it 30
seconds in either direction believe me
there is no context uh which
makes that uh anything other than
entirely nonsensical and hilarious
no no no that was breaking news
according to cnn that's not nonsensical
stephen right that is a story that the
american people
must hear well you know how dare you
let's find something that's more in his
wheelhouse this one's another one from
uh
joe biden we gotta for example
why in god's name don't we teach
history in history classes
a black man invented the light bulb not
a white guy named edison
okay okay first off now all outside
we're going to get to why that is
just historically inaccurate but you may
have missed this play that again
just can you play that just the first
clip again yes all right from the start
we gotta for example
why in god's name don't we teach all
right hold on we're gonna pause
history and history classes a black man
and men at the library
now guys listen to this this is not
edited this is not edited play
a white guy named edison okay did you
guys hear it right there did you hear it
do you hear that ben we i swear to you
this is not edited we're gonna do this
original audio we amplified the sound i
swear to you
let's let's show that example amplified
version why in god's name don't we
teach history in history classes
a black man and men at the light bulb
not a white guy named edison
okay that is amplified sound yes that i
mean he's bending over
amplified sounds someone followed us
they're all looking at me like can we
say this let's go listen
when they played this when we were i
heard i hide the clip i thought it was i
thought it was us playing a joke and i
was like oh that's kind of funny
same thing no that's just amplified and
i know bill
he's a lawyer he's not entirely
convinced but we actually have the
exclusive uh reverse shot of the
reporter in the front row too
wow that's it that's it defamation case
destroyed
yeah i know that we shortchanged
ourselves with that clip that is
absolutely true
and here's the thing it may not be uh
former vice president joe biden
by somebody when you bend over as an old
man you know
using your upper body as like a a a
monkey wrench
torque and you better go at that exact
moment we could forgive him
we are going to assume that you are
guilty yeah that's just
is it ageist that may be yeah
very well may be true that may be and
that is
you know people always say what's the
cut-off for president when
you are walking around farting like
you're wearing rubber clogs and you're
the only one who doesn't know it for me
that is okay you're done yeah and mr
biden you know what they say about
people who denied it
right he who denied it yeah i don't i
don't want to you know look at any
applications if i got to choose between
a president who knows he can bend over
in his 70s and one who can't
you know just doesn't realize that he
shouldn't i mean i'm gonna go with the
one who's not gonna fart
at us at a peace summit oh also yeah
only
trump did the peace summit okay i see
what you did there as opposed to
broccoli he did the beer summit
oh i remember that uh cornell west liked
himself some blue moon
yeah that's when that's when all the
racial healing started yes yeah yeah
that's good
i'm getting my timeline mixed up is that
before or after the massive drone
strikes and civilian deaths
oh during they could be congruent was
that when he funded terrorism
temporarily in iran
all right by the way hit the
notification bell uh
if you are watching this on youtube we
do this show every morning right now up
to election
at 10 00 a.m eastern we have a special
stream of course next thursday the trump
town hall that'll be fun
um and i want to move on here uh
to the fact checking the farts are funny
great they are they're fun they're funny
and i think the live stream is tuesday
right not you said thursday i think it's
tuesday it's a tuesday it's a tuesday
tuesday it's a tuesday you said thursday
i'm saying
oh you're correct i'm just making sure
thank you very much got it i didn't fart
not really i corrected the record
it's opened over even cnn by the way
fact checked this and said that biden
was wrong a black man did not involve
inventor light but he did do is he
improved the filament
uh i think he created like a carbon
filament that lasted longer than
edison's light bulb so here's an example
like
this is how you know it's race-baiting
by the way is if a guy goes
oh it's black and white and black guy
good and white guy
lied and it's not even true he's so
desperate for a narrative
that we somehow have given credit to a
random white guy for inventing
one of the greatest modern creations
that anyone can possibly imagine
it changed the way that we live our
lives for crying out loud
anyone say oh you're only giving credit
to him because he's a white guy it's
actually a black guy and it's
not true he improved the light bulb
after it was invented and this was a guy
he worked with alexander graham bell um
that's something great to say
that's something great to say yeah
exactly look the latimer improvement to
the light bulb is undeniable but
essentially what joe biden said was
all of you teachers out there you're
complicit in this system yeah
exactly because if you accept this false
fact
yeah then you're all bad people and it's
not even like okay
who invented the telephone alexander
graham bell or vonage
they kind of adapted it it's a bad
example because they didn't improve i
used to get those calls on my internet
line right
now i picked up they go hello
vonage i said wait are you calling from
vonage to sell me vonage
and they just they just said i know and
hung up
yeah i'll call you back later i said
don't miss it all right it's a tough job
we can't it's about as good as the uh
the recent gallup polling i get it most
people
frankly sir we were just surprised that
you answered your phone
we're surprised we got through i'm an
ex-con who hates my life living at a
call center sir can you just say that
you spoke with me so i can check it off
my list
yeah you know who put me here kamala
bill clinton
no kamala harris said i couldn't leave
until i met my quota
what were you about to say i was about
to say that uh you know obviously this
was when he was in kenosha right
he wasn't in kenosha this morning i
don't think he was i don't think he was
in
kenosha like late last night so the news
agencies have had time to go
hey he said this and the reason that i
say that is because uh this whole
army thing that's going on right now for
veterans and soldiers
attacking trump sarah huckabee sanders
is it i think she's gonna be in the show
uh tomorrow oh nice well that's
fantastic she was defending donald trump
saying i've been in the
oval office when he's had to make calls
to people who have lost their sons and
inform them of that
cnn has run over and over and over that
that is a bold-faced lie the president
does not notify them he calls for
condolences
right they have run segments because she
misspoken said informed instead of
condolences
he said somebody invented the light bulb
that didn't and they have not run
one single correction or challenge of
anything
that's the only comparison that you need
she was obviously saying his heart is
broken when he has to call parents
and talk to them about that like
farrakhan going on how much did you
think
ben franklin was out there with this
kite and [ __ ] really it was a guy named
seymour with a belt buckle
we was king i don't know if that is
accurate that's because
maybe you a jew oh there we go
back to your quadrant on cuomo's prime
time program
i'm so tired of this crap like why this
is just
what do you think happens with white
kids when they're watching this they're
told by don lemon well you can get a
loan because like what what is
what is a loan and then you have every
single opportunity available to them and
then they say by the way we're also
going to erase the fact that a white guy
invented a light bulb because it might
offend some people black people have
contributed
like it could have been nuanced too i
don't know why he picked that he could
have said hey
elvis presley didn't even rock and roll
he ripped it off a lot of lighting but
yeah okay that makes sense we understand
yeah yeah
it's like someone told them that in the
green room and they're in the wings or
someone said hey by the way joe biden i
don't know if you know this but uh
actually a black guy i meant a lightbulb
no [ __ ] i'm gonna use that he just
walked out
i'm running with that you know it's
funny it was it was it was donald trump
he was back there he was like joe joe
joe breaking news
he's like okay who are you all right it
was donald trump with a black mission
impossible mask
uh black guy invited a light bulb it'll
kill biden walked off on him
[Laughter]
to the camera
i will do a shoulder roll though because
that looks weak
yeah i will walk with my head well you
don't look very inconspicuous
i am so i'm so conspicuous that no one
will dare
notice me that's not how it works i
don't think so uh all right so anyway
uh it's a lie it's not true i don't want
to say it's a lie because he didn't even
use the name of the guy
uh latimer i think that he just i think
i don't i don't know that's lie it's
just inaccurate and it is a lie
though of omission for the media to not
cover it right
when they do the 20 000 lies that donald
trump has told and you actually read
what they are like he said he was
wearing a button fly when if you look at
here it was clearly a zipper fly you
know something like that it's like
why does this matter yeah this guy just
said that one of the greatest
inventors of all time uh shouldn't be
considered one of the greatest members
of all time
yeah and look i would i would give him a
pass saying that he misspoke right but
that
the rules of the game right now are
picking apart every single sentence that
everybody speaks
on the right and saying that they're
liars because of it and on the left it's
like oh well no we'll give them the
benefit of the day i give joe biden
the demented old farting circus monkey
pass i don't give it to cnn my problem
my main grievous is with cnn abc nbc cbs
it's with the media
it's with the cultural establishment joe
biden is a
he's a tool this whole idea of a
manchurian candidate this whole idea of
a puppet
there is no more of an empty vessel that
exists
we're beyond empty suit an empty vessel
he's like one of those tubes in futurama
with the the
helmet he's an empty tube that will be
whatever the democratic party wants him
to be
and the democratic party doesn't know
what they want to be right now except
that they're okay with violence and
radical socialism
my problem my major agreements is with
the media i don't despise but i
really don't even harbor any ill i kind
of feel sorry for him i do too i'm
wondering if his son can stop collecting
checks for you know uh not snake oil but
oil oil if he can stop collecting checks
for his energy companies to tell his
debt you know what hey
maybe time to maybe time to call it
quits dad it said it's maybe time for
you to start to
start winding down vp was a little high
so let's not shoot any higher
okay the walking parts around the white
house i mean they have cameras and
recording devices everywhere so they're
going to he's the kind of guy who's
going to walk in slippers in the carpet
and electrocute himself grabbing the
door handle
he'll be out for a day all right kamala
you're right that's me too
oh here we go they're now talking about
dan uh talking about daniel
several high-ranking officials submitted
paperwork to retire cnn's alexandra
field
has more good let's give her an accurate
coverage here because the
original headlines are misleading
singletary the police chief in rochester
says he is retiring because of the
mischaracterization and politicization
of his
actions in the uh in the aftermath of
the death of daniel pruitt for some
context here
there have been accusations that
information about the death was withheld
uh there has also been sparring with the
mayor's office over actually no the
accusations were initially
racist he didn't say that now that they
have the it's tough to do when you have
that
overlay of the black guy right there
zooming in on accusations that it was uh
mishandled really how is it mishandled
uh well we didn't know that this man
looked this way
when we accused the police it was very
dark in the video really we probably
should have waited for more facts
overall and we certainly didn't know
that he was black
um but we would never accuse you we saw
the badge and said bad guy
right the badge and that's our mad guy
and don't forget to add him to the list
right you've got um just a couple days
ago the chief of police in the city of
dallas
yep first black woman to be the chief
police in the city of dallas uh
largely criticized for taking a stand
against the violence right some of the
protesters in dallas
uh retired uh or resigned or gave her
his resignation i think we have some
overlays for that yeah
we have uh yeah dallas portland yeah
police
resigned also edelman uh i believe it
was a black woman
uh and yeah yeah portland dallas seattle
and not to mention there have been
entire
uh shifts of police who weren't the
chiefs who have walked off
city of atlanta don't forget their woman
chief of police resigned
yeah yeah wow there's no benefit to
being a police officer being in that
i've got to imagine that recruitment is
at an all-time
low right now let me show you the clip
because we've done this with dion kj
again this is my challenge out there
okay i want everyone
send me one one video of
a a minority suspect a minority basic
pullover not even a suspect someone
who's speeding who gets pulled over by a
white cop
and as being polite hands at ten and two
saying hey officer i'm a concealed carry
pro bang bang bang bang bang
something like that nothing is even
close jacob blake ah dion kay
ah mike brown ray chart brooks at daniel
pruitt
not even close just find me one
video that suits the narrative that you
have been
out pushing recently that there is that
there is
license to execute innocent black men
in the streets if you're a police
officer that is what they are running on
it's not based on statistical fact more
white people are shot by police officers
and a higher percentage of white people
are shot by police officers when you
take into account police interactions
it's not based on fact but even
anecdotally you're rioting in the
streets
over something that i'm about to show
you guys usually people would warn you
and say this is graphic i'll tell you
what this man does die daniel uh
mr uh prude but this video is not
graphic what you are going to see is
exactly what the public has seen what is
outrageous keep in context if there was
a phone call made because he was
absolutely out of his mind
and you can hear his interactions with
the officer uh
this is what has sparked the outrage in
the community
where now a black police chief is
resigning this is daniel proof
now give me the man give me the man give
me the mates
yes yes i mean so they put on the uh
spit hood
this isn't there early outbreak of
copenhagen give me the gun
not me all right all right all right
take this
you know it's crazy look at how loud he
is
this is the most violent portion
the guy's talking very clearly his head
is to the side there isn't a knee on his
neck
there isn't a knee on his torso calm
down
stop calm down
a reenactment of a clan rally if i've
ever seen one calm down sir
give me a gun give me again he's talking
about his big penis when you watch the
full video
he's out of his mind i understand it
we're compassionate someone is out of
their mind but guess what
officers need to go home too yeah and do
we have to act like people who've been
out of their mind who need psychiatric
help
haven't harmed people especially when
they're spitting and chanting
give me your gun give me your gun i got
a big dick
yeah that last part that really seals it
he'd already been taken in for suicidal
behavior okay
he was running naked he was asking for
their guns he told them he had coveted
he was spitting so
take it up with fauci in the fouchy hood
by the way that is
far less people talk about how the
oxygenate it's not a problem with the
coven masks
those things are far less thick than
it's basically like a linen shirt that a
drug dealer would use
it's a pablo escobar show linen
yeah and i mean it's obviously like you
you can't just come out and say hey this
is really sad that this happened right
there was no
it didn't seem like the cops were racist
the cops didn't say anything bad the
cops weren't mistreating him beating him
they weren't
brutal no exactly that's what i'm saying
so we could all have come together and
say ah gosh we got to figure out how
that doesn't happen like how did this
happen what went wrong
i'll tell you what i'll go to bed
because systemically maybe we can find
out how to do but uh individually
don't do pcp well then yeah that's
probably the medical examiner's report
said something about his
asphyxiation from physical restraint
which i don't believe i'm sorry i don't
buy i watched it i physically
restrained people many many times i know
what asphyxiation is as someone who does
grappling
uh the guy was on pp pcp he was an
excited delirious they probably
should have controlled him more they
should have controlled
no control over that guy is far more
likely to hurt himself if he can roll
around on the ground and cut himself on
rocks his handcuffs can get wedged he
can break a rib yeah they should have
controlled him better
they didn't all it was kind of hold his
head down sideways
again we need better training for police
officers uh but in this case
they should have been more controlling i
would have liked to see an ncaa
style pin at that point so the guy
couldn't move so he's not a harm to
himself
or to officers right we teach this to
people who work in mental institutions
i have family members who do guess do
you know what a straitjacket is
learn to become a human straight jacket
that's what they teach these people to
subdue
mentally disturbed patients right or
people on pcp who can't feel pain at all
and will just keep incredibly right
you're about to say something there
you know when it when it comes to it i
just can't help but think that these
officers clearly were trying to do
their job there was no far away from any
kind of animus
but if what we're saying is that these
officers need to be trained better
it just runs counter to everything that
blm is pushing right now yeah and
and everything that's going out there in
the narrative it isn't less funding it's
more funding it's more funding
to get better training if we all agree
that there's a training issue
not in every department not every
officer right but if there is a training
issue
right then we are all agreed in needing
to fund the police
more and you know what the only view
that is consistent is the view of
conservatives who believe in
in more training meaning more funding
right now so it's proper because
you look at governor whitmer in michigan
well she's defunding the police she
wants to defend the police she's
upgrading her own security by over a
million dollars
right now but why would you need to do
that yeah why do you think that
now i have no problem with someone who
has private security just don't tell me
that because i can't afford private
security i can't carry my own firearm
which is a constitutionally protected
right i have no problem with someone
having
hounds that they can release and having
fences and having gates walls work i
have no problem with them having
a ring doorbell system whatever the hell
it is that you guys you have no problem
updating
uh up upgrading their security just
don't tell me that my municipal police
have to be defunded because you need
more votes
they are not consistent with this you
see it with you see it with the mayor in
portland
who left his condo you see it in
missouri with that
uh prosecutor with the mccloskeys who's
like i'm actually under threat so i need
to be safe here
and you see it with the governor of
michigan so there is security for me
and not for the i'm saying hey how about
security for everybody that would be a
very nice thing for everybody keep
all the people safe because it's one of
the few legitimate roles of the
government how about we start with that
well then if you want to ask a question
who in america really you know who in
america really thinks that you need to
rely on yourself to defend
ask the millions of people who are
first-time gun owners during coronavirus
yes the millions who signed up since the
george floyd riots right i mean these
are individuals of
all ages skin colors ethnicities
religions
backgrounds who are saying i don't
believe
that i can be safe without having
something to defend myself with
and and i'm i'm not going to be a part
of anyone
any party any candidate who says i don't
think a young woman should be able to
defend herself
right she's not going to be a part of it
and i don't think any true american
is a would not should knowingly even
more than that not only will they say i
don't believe that a woman should be
able to defend herself but when a woman
is allegedly sexually assaulted as we
saw with jacob blake and goes through
the process
of notifying police officers having a
restraining order put out there's an
active warrant for jacob blake's arrest
and then he breaks back into her house
steals her keys and she calls the
officers again and says
hey remember that guy reported for rape
he's here thank you ma'am for doing the
right thing we'll stay in constant
communication
the media not a peep because they don't
care about the victims unless they are
useful for them that day right now in
any other scenario this black police
chief should be if you were out there
bashing trump
like they've done with military
officials who may have at some point
done a tour they were a private and got
out who knows
there are a lot of people coming out
here like i was in the military at one
time
oh why are you dishonorably discharged
these are details
i hate donald trump they would do that
with this police uh sergeant let me read
you his quote
okay this is a quote from the police
chief
he said that uh he had a problem with
the mischaracterization
and the politicization of the actions
that i took after being formed of mr
prude's death
as a man of integrity i will not sit
idly by
while outside entities attempt to
destroy my character
the events over the past week are an
attempt to destroy my character and
integrity
hey sergeant welcome to the club because
we've been experiencing that for a long
time that's what the left does
they destroy your character to try and
say that you're no longer a story worth
telling that you are not a valuable tool
for them
now notice something else we read the
quote talking about the assassination on
character how it bothers this man how
he's been an upstanding police sergeant
by all metrics that we have available to
us by all reports we didn't say
hey white people blame black officer
because that's not what matters you know
what matters a good man is being blamed
for doing something wrong
but not only i will say with daniel
pruitt not only didn't do anything wrong
these police did the right thing
including the ones who are minorities
you let me again send that send me one
send me one video just like chris cuomo
with one dunk
one dunk and a ten foot one that's right
you can send me one and i'll give you 20
tries
we are going to go uh exclusive two
monthly we're gonna play bad movie lines
and read some of your chat
tomorrow we have sarah huckabee sanders
on
the show we love you appreciate you
freeloaders though it is time to join
for right now
youtube piss off